[Müzik]
buraya hazırlanırken açıkçası hayattaki
çok büyük eksiklikleri görme şansım oldu
bir tanesi kızımın neden teknoloji
sevmediğini Anladım bunu yanlış
yetiştirmiş Çünkü çok araştırma yaptım
yani insanların teknolojiyle barışması
için ne yapmak gerekiyor diye çok yanlış
yoldan gitmişim ikinci gördüğüm büyük
Sorun da beyinle ilgili sağ taraftaki
kadın beyini sol taraftaki erkek beyni
erkek beyni böyle biraz köşeli bir şey
içinde kompartmanlar var ve o
kompartmanlar Her biri bir konuya
ayrılmış işte aşk iş para neyse eğitim
ve bu kompartmanlar arasında pek geçiş
yapamıyor O yüzden erkekler bir anda bir
tek şeyi yapabiliyorlar kumlar arasında
da bağlantı kuramıyor Şimdi Özlem
Ata'dan girdi Samsun'dan çıktı Ne
olduğum mu şaşırdım konu arasındaki
bağlantılar Biz erkekler Tek bir şeyi
becerebilir sabin hanımla beraber Pınar
da burada bugün konuşmacı kahvaltı
yaparken fark ettim ben sunuma kitlenmiş
durumdayım ve sunumda bir görüntünün
karesinin doğru oturmasına çalışıyorum
Pınar o sırada evde çocuğu organize
ediyor O gün nerede eğleneceği bir andan
garson hanımla sohbet ediyor kahvaltımız
la ilgili bir takım detaylar çözüyor ve
bir yandan sunumuna bakabiliyor Ben ise
bir dakika en önemli şeyi yapıyorum
şunun köşesi denk gelmedi seviyesindeyim
o yüzden biraz köşeli bir tip olduğumu
bir anlamakta fayda var geçelim slayda
ve benim hayatımda o köşelerin
içerisinde o karelerin içerisindeki en
büyük yerde para kaplıyor ben parayı
seviyorum ve diyorum ki kadınlara ne
anlatabilirim bugün diye kendime
sorduğumda Parayla bu teknoloji
ilişkisini biraz kuralım dedim Çünkü ene
sonunda para önemli yani hayatta
özgürlük istiyorsak hayatta
istediklerimize ulaşmak istiyorsak bunun
parayla bir bağlantısı var Ben de
Parayla bu bağlantıya bugün biraz
yardımcı olmak istiyorum teknoloji
bağlantısı kurmak istiyorum uzun
yıllardır yatırımcıyı geçelim bir slaytı
daha yatırım yapıyorum derken de ya
böyle Altın toprak arsa o işler anlamam
teknolojiye yatırım yapıyorum Çok iyi
gitti biraz dah şanslı deydim ve o gün
bugündür de teknoloji alanında sürekli
yatırımlarda bulunuyorum Bu da beni bu
da beni kariyerimle başka bir yere doğru
götürdü Ve Teknoloji yatırımcılığı la
ilgili YouTube kanalı açtım işte öyle de
hasper Kader youtuber da oldum ama
teknolojiyle ilgili bildiklerim
öğrendiklerim benim önüme çok yeni
yollar açtı Çünkü şunu gördüm insan
teknolojiyi bilirse bir kere girişimci
olabiliyor ondan bahsedeceğim ve kadın
erkek olmanız fark etmez teknolojiyi
anlayabiliyorsun girişimci
olabiliyorsunuz ikincisi ya ben
girişimci olmayacağım Ben yatırım yapmak
istiyorum diyorsanız teknolojiye yatırım
yapmak mümkün yani paranızla başkaları
sizin için çalışsın Mesela elan musk
benim için deli gibi çalışıyor her gün
ben de bekliyorum Para kazandırsın bize
diye üçüncüsü yeni teknolojilerle
üretkenliğin artırabilirsiniz çok daha
verimli olabilirsiniz ve son olarak da
Çevrenizdeki değişime Öncü olabilirsiniz
O benim yapabildiğim en duygusal anı
olacak konuşmanın daha fazlasını
beklemeyin ok şimdi biraz para konuşalım
Evet atlayalım bir slayt şimdi teknoloji
girişimci demek aslında iki şeyi
kapsıyor Bence bir tanesi bir tarafta
bir teknolojik trend var işte bu
ekrandaki arkadaş Amazon Jeff bezos onun
kurucusu şunu görüyor Diyor ki ya bu
internet işi büyüyecek e internet
insanlar Muhtemelen bir şeyler de alıp
satmak isteyebilirler ne yapayım ben
evdeki kitaplardan başlıyor daha sonra
yavaş yavaş büyüterek internetten Kitap
yazmaya başlıyor satmaya başlıyor işte
dünyanın Bugün de en zengin insanlardan
bir tanesi bu ana mesele yani burada bir
teknoloji var burada da insanların çöz
MEye çalıştığı bir problem var Özellikle
Jeff bezos o zamanlar Nadir kitaplara
odaklanıyor herkesin yapabileceği bir
şey bunda bir cinsiyet ayrımı açıkçası
hiç görmüyorum atlayalım bir slaytta
Nitekim dünyadan harika örnekler var
Mesela bu hanımefendinin adı Melanie
Perkins Melanie Perkins kanva kurucusu
kanva bugün piyasa değeri 26 milyar
dolar civar Reader da iyi gidiyor
İnşallah göreceğiz hocam oralarda 26
milyar dolara nasip etsin ve baktığımda
hikayesine daha Evel bir tasarımcı
grafik tasarımcı mevcut grafik tasarım
yazılımlarının çok ilkel olduğunu
kullanmayı çok kullanmasın çok zor
olduğunu görüyor Ve kanva kuruyor belki
vardır kanva kullanan aranızda hiç
yazılımdan anlamayan bir insanın bile
grafik tasarımcısı olmasını sağlıyor Biz
bütün görsellerimiz kapaklarımız her
şeyimizi kanva sayesinde yapabiliyoruz
Avustralya'da bir girişimci daha evvel
bir iki tane küçük girişimleri var Ve
sonra bu yolu alıyor ama Türkiye'den de
harika örnekler var alalım bir tane daha
mesela Demet Hanım Belki de buraya
gelmiştir daha Evel bilmiyorum
Gelmediyse davet etmenizi tavsiye ederim
trent yolunun kurucusu Amerika'da okuyor
orada bir danışmanlık şirketinde
çalışıyor Türkiye'ye geldiğinde
Türkiye'de e ticaretin erkeklerin elinde
olduğunu görüyor O zamanlar bir
Markafoni diye bir şey vardı hatırlıyor
muyum hatırlayanlar var mı bilmiyorum
sonra ortadan kayboldu ve şunu fark
ediyor Çok da doğru bir şey fark ediyor
Markafoni Daha ziyade fabrika
fazlalarını satmak için kurulmuş bir yer
moda duygusu yok o Şahane kadın gözü yok
dünyaya anlama Yok e ben Bu çerçevede
Trend yolu kurayım diyor bugün işte
Trend yolunun büyüklüğünü hepimiz
biliyoruz bir slayt daha atlayalım
hanımefendi Hande çilingir belki
tanıyanlar var ınsider kurucusu ınsider
Türkiye'den çıkan ilk unicorn
girişimlerden bir tanesi unicorn demek 1
milyar dolar üzeri değerlemeye ulaşan
bütün dünyada da şu anda hizmetler
Veriyor Hande Hanım Eskiden bir beyaz
yakalı profesyonel daha sonra Özellikle
büyük şirketlerin teknoloji yazılımı
meselesinde Özellikle de pazarlama
yazılımları konusunda zorlandığını
görüyor Ben buna bir çözüm getirebilir
miyim ve macerasına başlıyor her
seferinde aynı hikayeyi görüyoruz bir
teknolojik trend var o teknolojik
trendin çözebileceği bir müşteri
problemi var Ben bu ikisini birleştirmek
için ne yapabilirim ama diyebilirsiniz
ki ya hocam ben bu yaşa kadar böyle
yazılım da teknolojiyle bu işlerle çok
da uğraşmadım yine de girişimci olabilir
Teknoloji sayesinde ama Atlım bir slayt
daha benim çok heyecanla bir slayt daha
geçebilir miyiz Teşekkür ederim benim
çok heyecanla Takip ettiğim dünyada Bir
akım var yaratıcılık ekonomisi deniyor
Yani bir şey yaratabilen insanların bunu
piyasayla müşteriyle buluşması
kolaylaşmış durumda yine Teknoloji
sayesinde yani işte Her gittiğim yerde
sağ olsun birkaç kişi geliyor hocam
diyor işte senin yüzen hisse aldık
battık falan Neyse böyle şeylerde
yaşıyoruz tabii ama Her gittiğim yerde
bir iki tanıyan çıkıyor Allah'a şükür
Niye Çünkü YouTube sayesinde fikrimi
görüşümü bütün dünyaya aktarabilir yurt
dışına da çıkıyor işte bu yaratıcılık
ekonomisinin gücü bir şey üretip
yarattığın zaman sen bunu bütün dünyayla
Buluştur biliyorsun yani üretip
yaratacağını çok da önemli bir şey
olmayabilir Ben 6ı üstü hisse senetleri
konusunda konuşuyorum yani öyle bir
büyük bir yaratıcı olduğumu da
düşünmüyorum Ama eğer anlattığınız şey
ilginç ve bunu samimiyetle yapıyorsanız
özeniyorsun iyi bilgiler veriyorsanız
bütün dünya bunu merak ediyor işte Bu
çerçevede de başka bir girişimci geçelim
lütfen tanıştırmak isteyeceğim bir
hanımefendi var aranızda Exel tablosu
iyi yapan var mı Exel uzmanı önden
çıktığı Exel dünyanın en önemli yazılımı
galiba Bana sorarsanız dünyadaki en
büyük eğitim pazarı yabancı deil eğitim
pazarıdır ikinci en büyüğü Excel demiş
700 milyon civarında kişi her gün Excel
kullanıyor işte bir tablo programı
biliyorsunuz onda bir şeyler yapıyor bu
kız cazda bu covid öncesinde E bir
danışmanlık firmasında çalışıyor işte
covid olup eve kapanınca Böyle bir
hayatı sorguluyor siz de yaptınız mı
bilmiyorum Yani böyle bir hayatı
sorguladık ya Ben ne yapıyorum falan
filan diye bu kız cağız bu danışmanlık
işinde işte sıkılıyor kendi işimi
kurayım Ne yapayım deyince Excel
dersleri verebilirim diyor fakat değişik
bir yoldan g Instagram'da ve tiktok'ta
kısa videolar yapmaya başlıyor çok da
eğlenceli videolar işte videoda bir
yandan dans ediyor zaten sevimli bir
hanımefendi Burada da yukarıda bir Exel
tablosu var orada bir problemi çözüyor
işte patron senden şöyle bir rapor
istediğinde onu şaşırmanın yolu falan
diyor Çok da eğlenceli videolar ve
acayip yürüyor bir anda işte bütün dünya
çapında 45 milyon takipçiye ulaşıyor ve
bunun sonunda bir gün diyor ki ya ben
size daha ciddi Exel eğitimleri de
verebilirim işte bizim de var ya böyle
udem falan gibi eğitim platformları onun
gibi bir ortam üzerinden Excel
eğitimleri vermeye başlıyor çok
beğeniliyor Hatta Microsoft'un ilgisini
çekiyor Microsoft diyor ki ya diyor
bizim diğer ürünlerin de eğitimlerini
sen versene işte word'ü PowerPoint falan
hatta şu anda kızımız e Microsoft'un
yönetim kurulunda yeni ürün geliştirme
projelerinde danışmanlık da veriyor ve
bir yandan da dünyayı geziyor Çok tatlı
bir sevgilisi var Onunla beraber
sevgilisini fotoğrafçı yapmış bu arada
Adam oyna Bunu fotoğraflıyor Video
çekiyor böyle Yurtdışına tatile eşiyle
giden Beyler varsa yaşamış olabilirler
buna bir bir bur çek falan Neyse adam
bunu görev ediş kendine bir yandan
dünyayı geziyorlar bu işleri yapıyorlar
bu yeni dünyanın gücü işte Sen yeter ki
bir şey üret
yaratabilen doğru gidiyoruz atlayalım
bir slayt daha ikinci konumuz para ya
para önemli çünkü hepimizin Eline gün
geliyor birazdan fazla bir para geçiyor
Türkiye'de o parayı ne yapıyoruz dersek
gidip çeyrek altın alıyoruz benim
gözlemim Bu çerçevede dünyada altına bu
kadar meraklı iki toplum var Hintliler
Bir de Biz Türkler özellikle hanımlar
için altın ve gayrimenkul bir numaralı
yatırım Pek doğru bir yatırım değil ama
atlim bir slaytta Ben de bunu uzun
zamandır savunuyorum İşte bunun için
YouTube kanalı kurdum 70 80.000 takipçi
var Şu sağ tarafta şurada görebiliyor
musunuz bilmiyorum O rakam biraz tuhaf
çıkmış takipçi kadın sayısı % 5.9 halı
saha maç gibiyiz sürekli bir slayt daha
atlayalım İlla böyle acayip hisse
senetlerini anlamanıza bile gerek yok bu
arada daha da basit bir iş bu
gidiyorsunuz burada üstte Biraz zor
gözüküyor bir tane fon var q q q diye
başka fonlar da var reklamını yapmayım
1000 tane fon var o fonu alıyorsunuz
orada neler var teknoloji şirketleri var
getiri buradan görebildiğim kadarıyla %
400 civarında son 10 yılda altını
görüyorsunuz aşağıda hala ölü takılıyor
paranızı yönetmel isiniz Bu kadar basit
ya bunu yapmıyorsunuz çeyrek altın
alıyorsunuz yapmayın Çünkü Eninde
sonunda Servet büyütmem de gerekiyor bir
yandan ister girişim olmak isteyelim
ister çevremize katkıda bulunmak
isteyelim değil mi bu işlerde bedava
olmuyor kim sponsor olmuşsa Allah razı
olsun her şey parayla ve bu paramızı iyi
kötü kazandığımız paramızı nasıl
değerlendirdiğimiz Önemli tabii şimdi
şöyle yapmayalım hocam o gün sen dedin
ben test aldım düştü yok Yavaş yavaş
sakin sakin teknoloji tarafında
yatırımcı olun bir de Türkiye'den de ne
güzel işte şim Reader gibi çok hoş
örnekler çıkmaya başladı bugün de o
yönden de şanslı oldu Özden orada bir
arada olmak onları da düşünmek gayet
mümkün Özen fiyat iyi mi bu sıralar Ne
diyorsun bir içeriden bir bilgi versen
bize 3 be
vermedi ve baktığımda kadın girişimci
efsaneleri var araştırdım Legendary
Human investors diye müthiş bir makaleye
denk geldim bunları okuyun ne yapıyorlar
bunlar yani bunlar Tabii bu işi daha
profesyonelce yapan insanlar çok
enteresan bir araştırma sonucu
göstereyim size vanguard diye bir fon
yönetim şirketi var Amerika'da bunların
da bir yatırım Platformu var bir
araştırma yapıyorlar en başarılı
yatırımcıların ortak özelliği nedir
Erkek mi Bunlar kadın mı genç mi yaşlı
mı hiçb değil ölü ölenlerin yatırım
getirisi daha iyi çünkü Ölmüş adam
oynayamam hisselerle Biz erkekler öyle
değiliz biz oynamayı seviyoruz O hisseyi
alacağız satacağız hocam trendi
yakaladık iniyor dip falan kaybolup
gidiyoruz ölünce rahat hisse duruyor
yavaş yavaş büyüyor kadınlar bu konuda
daha iyi mesela Japon kadınları dünyanın
en başarılı yatırımcı kitlesi içinde
bulunuyor Çünkü alıyorlar tutuyorlar Abi
bu kadınların sabrı daha geniş Çünkü siz
bir çocuk yetiştirme güdüsü var müthiş
bir şey yani bir güzel bir çocuğun Ata
gibi güzel bir çocuğun ortaya çıkmasının
nasıl Emek istediği nasıl zaman aldığını
biliyorsunuz iyi bir şirketin ortaya
çıkması zaman alan bir şey işte büyüyor
ve kadınlar buna sabr edebiliyor
erkekler edemiyor Ozan yatırım Bence
işin ikinci boyutu üçüncü boyut Tabii
bir yandan da üretkenliği artırabiliriz
ben yapay zekayı inanılmaz yoğun
kullanıyorum sizi boğmak istemem
detayları jgp çıktığından beri çok da
yoğun kullanıyorum cgp Çok acayip yani
burada birçok rahatsız edici bir
istatistik var mesela Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde Baro sınavlarında chat
cpi şu anda insanların % 0'dan daha iyi
performans gösteriyor 4 ay önce %
10'undan daha iyi performans
gösteriyordu versiyon değişti performans
buraya geldi yani buradan cet gpt gibi
çözümleri kendimize rakip olarak
düşünebiliriz veyahut da ya ben bunları
nasıl kullanırım da üretkenliği mi artar
diyebiliriz ve bunlardan yüzlercesi var
şu anda binlercesi var her konuda Verim
artırabiliyor Ben yapay zekayla
tanışmadan önce bir YouTube videosunun
düşünmem üretip web siteme yüklememe
kadar geçen süre 2 gün civarıydı ve
zaman zaman dışarıdan destek de
alıyordum şu an 3 saat tamamını kendim
yapabiliyorum çünkü şu ekranda
gördüğünüz işte bazı örneklerini verdim
Yapay Zeka programları sayesinde her
şeyi çok hızlı çok teknik çok üretken
yapabiliyorum sofya'dan daha hızları var
hızları var Bu arada mesela Sofia demin
ağ senkronu tutturamadı a senkronu 7
dilde benim yüzümden tutturan yazılımlar
var şu anda Sofia biraz eskimiş böyle bu
dünya Çünkü bunları kullanırsak
üretkenliği artar üretkenlik artarsa ne
olur iki şey olur bir tanesi bir yerde
diyelim profesyonel kariyer yapıyorsunuz
yükselirsin Bir üretken olmayan Mehmet
var burada üretken olan özem var bitti
cinsel ayrım falan herkes üretkenliğin
peşinde bitti yürürsün ikincisi Belki
kendi işini yapıyorsan benim örneğim
olduğu gibi daha fazla üretirsin daha
fazla ortaya koyarsın yapmanız gereken
şey de basit Bunlarla biraz oynayın çok
olaylara yazıyorsunuz Yani beni
yakışıklı göster
beceremedi kitleri bayağı bir uğra
göbeğimi biraz küçült chat gpen cevap
kendin küçült Neyse Yani her şey
yapamıyorlar ama bayağı iyi işler
yapıyorlar ve olduğumuzdan çok daha hoş
hale gelip çok daha güzel içerikler
üretebiliyoruz ve tabii son olarak da
çevremizdeki değişimi yönetmemiz önemli
Biraz önce bahsettim kızımı
yetiştirirken çok hata yapışı
teknolojiyi sevmiyor şu anda kullanıyor
iyi bir okula girdi ama teknolojiyle
aşkı çok az benim kadar seven bir
insanlar Öyle olmaması gerekirdi ama
yanlış işler yapmışım Bugün Pınar kendi
konuşmasında neleri doğru yapmanız
gerektiğini bir ebeveyn olarak da
sizlerle anlatacak Çünkü oradan başlıyor
bütün süreç oradan başlıyor bütün
yolculuk ama hala yapılacak işler var bu
sunum için araştırma yaparken bu
hanımefendiye denk geldim dey Sterling
dey Sterling de bu arada bir tedex
konuşmacısı Mutlaka izleyin müthiş David
Sterling mühendis Mühendislik
fakültesinde okurken bir sorun
hissediyor diyor ki benim diyor uzamsal
becerilerim erkeklerden daha az olduğunu
gördüm Hani bu kadının yol bulamaması
esprisi falan var ya Hikaye oradan
geliyor Aslında ve araştırıyor acaba
diyor bunda bir şey mi var yani Beyinde
mi bir fark var genetik bir fark mı var
yok Tek fark erkek çocukları daha fazla
Lego gibi uzamsal ürünlerle oynuyorlar
Doğru mu bu kadar basit aslında yani
hani aldığınız hediye bile doğru
seçmenizde fayda var bu yönden peki Ne
yapabilirim diyor legoların kadınsı bir
versiyonunu yapıyor kadınların daha çok
seveceği inandığı kız çocuklarının Pek
işe yaramıyor Sonra işte şu ekranda
gördüğünüz setleri geliştirmeye başlıyor
ve bir yandan bu setler sayesinde kız
çocuk çocuklarının uzamsal düşüncesini
geliştiriyor bir yandan da başarılı bir
girişimcilere dönüşüyor Yani hep yapacak
bir şey var girişimci olabiliriz
yatırımcı olabiliriz üretkenliği
artırabiliriz veya çevremizi
dönüştürebiliriz bu telx konuşmalarını
da bu yönden çok seviyorum İnşallah
aranızda birkaçını da dönüşmek isteyecek
ve size diyorum ki bütün bu iş zihinsel
yani erkek şunda iyi kadın bunda iyi
falan bunlar zihinsel araştırmalar erkek
beyniyle kadın beyni arasında ciddi bir
fark görmüyor küçücük bir gramaj farkı
var gerçekten gramaj farkı var Onun
dışında hiçbir şey yok o gramaj farkı da
ne işe yiyor henüz tespit edilemedi
erkek beynin böyle bir boş bölgesi var
boş boş Bakıyoruz ya biz bazen o oraya
denk geliyor herhalde biz buyuz onun
dışında sıfır fark aynı becerilere
sahibiz Hatta daha fazla iletkene
sahipsiniz kadın beyninde daha fazla
beyaz maddeye sahipsiniz Bu sayede
bağlantılar kurabiliyorsunuz yepyeni
şeyler söyleyebiliyorsun bizde onlar yok
ama Zihni modeli değiştirmek başlıyoruz
teknoloji takip edin teknoloji okuyun
teknolojiyle ilgili şeyleri izleyin
Özlem gibi Samsun hemşireniz yaptınız p
geliyor konuşmaya Ben size söyleyeyim
Öz gelir Öz Özlem gibi konuşmacıları
çağırım bugün eşim Pınar konuşacak Pınar
da mesela doğrudan doğruya teknolojiye
yakın hiç olmadı ama Teknoloji süper
kullanıp bizim had aşımızı başı getirdi
haddini aşın diyoruz biz bunu ilk
söylediğimizde haddini bil hocam dediler
Türkiye'de herkes had bildiriyor
haddinizi bilmeyin daha iyisini
yapabiliriz teşekkür
ederim